el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
llegó al gobierno en 2022 con grandes
promesas de cambio en prácticamente
todos los sectores políticos sociales y
económicos del país digamos que el nuevo
presidente se propuso cambiar Colombia
de arriba a abajo uno de estos grandes
cambios es precisamente su plan de
transición energética el cual por mucho
que os pueda sorprender pasa por una
abrupto cese de cualquier nuevo contrato
de exploración y explotación de petróleo
en el territorio colombiano es decir por
el fin de la industria petrolera en el
país y ojo que hablamos de uno de los
sectores económicos más importantes que
más dinero aportan a las arcas públicas
y el número uno en término de
exportaciones la pregunta lógicamente es
Qué puede suponer para Colombia romper
con la industria petrolera por qué lo
hacen qué van a sacrificar con ello
tiene sentido una medida como ésta Pues
bien queridos amigos amigas En este
vídeo vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas arranquemos
[Música]
con unas reservas probadas de cerca de
2.000 millones de barriles Colombia se
encuentra entre los 35 países con
mayores reservas de oro negro de todo el
mundo en concreto en este país existen
23 zonas geológicas con diferentes
cuencas de las cuales sólo 9 producen
hidrocarburos 7 producen petróleo y dos
producen gas
de las siete cuencas productoras de
crudo solo tres concentran más del 90%
de la producción Estas son las cuencas
de los Llanos orientales del Valle medio
y Valle superior del Magdalena en total
de los 20 departamentos que extraen
petróleo actualmente solo uno extrae
petróleo ligero Mientras que el resto
producen crudo mediano o Pesado
bien Esto serían grosso modo los
detalles como veis el perfil petrolero
colombiano no es precisamente el de un
país como are saudí pero sí que tiene
mucho potencial Aunque eso sí vaya lo
que les costó aprovecharlo atentos
porque justo aquí comienza toda esta
historia
[Música]
los primeros pasos la alergia a la
rentabilidad
queridos amigos el primer pozo de
petróleo de toda la historia de Colombia
Se perforó ya en el año 1918 en el campo
cira infantas donde apenas se llegaban a
producir 2000 barriles diarios tres años
después se construyó la primera
refinería del país en barrancabermeja y
también el primero el octo en mamonal
muy cerca de Cartagena y de esta forma
es como hace ya algo más de 100 años se
puso en marcha la industria petrolera
colombiana sin embargo durante mucho
tiempo no se obtuvo ningún provecho de
esta industria Así que en 1951 buscando
darle un giro de tuerca a este asunto el
por aquel entonces gobierno de Laureano
Gómez nacionalizó y le otorgó varias
concesiones petroleras a la recién
formada empresa colombiana de petróleos
ecopetrol una empresa pública creada
para que el estado colombiano pues
pudiera participar activamente e
impulsar esta industria de esta forma
Aunque durante esos años gigantes como
Texaco o la sel comenzaron a interesar
por el petróleo colombiano Lo cierto es
que las condiciones de exploración y
extracción para ellas pues no eran
precisamente muy ventajosas Sin lugar a
dudas la presencia de ecopetrol era el
principal escollo el gobierno solo tenía
ojos para esta compañía y esta entidad
no solo era una empresa que competía en
la exploración y en la producción de
hidrocarburos sino que actuaba también
como el organismo público que regulaba
este sector así que de una forma u otra
digamos que todas las empresas privadas
pues estaban obligadas a asociarse con
su virtual competidor en condiciones muy
poco atractivas y así de esta forma
durante casi todo el siglo XX Lo cierto
es que se probaron distintos regímenes
jurídicos que a decir verdad parecían ir
de mal en peor
[Música]
por ejemplo entre 1974 y 1989 opera un
régimen llamado contrato 5050 que tenía
la misión de impulsar la inversión pese
a ello bajó este marco el socio privado
asumía el coste y el riesgo de la
inversión en exploración que tenía que
completarse en un plazo máximo de 3 años
eso sí cuando comenzaba la producción el
reparto del beneficio que quedaba se
hacía de la siguiente forma un 20% para
el estado en concepto de regalías un 40%
para ecopetrol y un 40% para el inversor
privado por supuesto luego el inversor
privado tenía que pagar los
correspondientes impuestos sobre los
beneficios el resultado entre el 85% y
el 90% de los beneficios de la
explotación y van a parar al Estado el
inversor privado apenas recibía el resto
lo que lógicamente resultaba muy poco
atractivo
en 1987 se trató de mejorar esta Norma
Aunque bueno tratar es mucho decir lo
único que se hizo fue que ecopetrol
tuviera una participación más alta en el
coste de la exploración pero no cambio
más grandes rasgos el modelo por eso en
1989 se puso en marcha un nuevo régimen
que estaría vigente hasta 1994 se creó
la figura conocida como contrato de
distribución de la producción en este
esquema el socio privado asumía el costo
y el riesgo exploratorio Hasta que
efectuaba el descubrimiento a partir de
ese momento ecopetrol entraba a
participar de la siguiente manera
ya lo veis Cuanto más rentable da el
pozo descubierto menos participación le
quedaba al inversor privado si este
modelo atrajo un aluvión de inversiones
lo debió hacer lejos del petróleo
colombiano porque de hecho un yacimiento
con apenas 60 millones de barriles ya
era de por sí escasamente rentable por
supuesto Este modelo no funcionó Así que
en 1995 se tuvo que lanzar una nueva
Fórmula en este caso denominada como
factor r en este caso la distribución de
la producción se hacía basándose en la
rentabilidad del campo petrolero es no
tenía en cuenta la magnitud de la
reserva el problema es que no era nada
fácil calcular los ingresos y los
beneficios esperados lo que producía
muchísima incertidumbre una
incertidumbre que por supuesto Pues
espantaba los inversores Así que ahora
Seguro seguro que ya entendéis por qué
durante Prácticamente todo el siglo XX
la riqueza petrolera de Colombia apenas
explotó Y eso que el mayor interesado de
que creciera la producción era
precisamente el propio estado que era
quien se llevaba la mayor parte de los
beneficios en concepto de impuestos y
regalías pero claro dicho esto estoy
convencido que ahora muchos tenéis la
solución en la cabeza parece bastante
obvia sin embargo queridos amigos amigas
esta tardó mucho en llegar atentos
[Música]
El despegue
no todo Estaba perdido durante la
presidencia de Andrés pastrana ecopetrol
dio un giro muy importante durante la
conocida como convocatoria de la ronda
2000 el estado hizo una serie de
concursos para explorar y producir en
proyectos en los que la empresa Estatal
solo tendría el 30% de la participación
por supuesto estas nuevas reglas de
juego sí que llamaron la atención de las
grandes petroleras del mundo y para que
os hagáis una idea esa iniciativa
culminó con la adjudicación de 13
proyectos con más de 600 millones de
dólares de inversión inicial sin embargo
con todo el gran cambio para el sector
petrolero colombiano aún estaba por
llegar en el año 2003 el por aquel
entonces presidente Álvaro Uribe Vélez
ordenó la reestructuración del sector
yendo directo a la raíz del problema el
entonces gobierno colombiano creó la
agencia Nacional de hidrocarburos de tal
forma que ecopetrol perdió sus
facultades de regulación de esta manera
la empresa pública pasó a estar enfocada
casi por completo a la exploración la
producción el transporte la refinación y
la distribución comercial de los
hidrocarburos es decir que se convirtió
así en una petrolera al uso al mismo
tiempo el gobierno puso en marcha un
nuevo contrato de regalías impuestos y
derechos
un nuevo modelo que imitaba a los
estándares Internacionales y que
limitaba la participación total del
estado A un Rango de entre el 50 y el
60% de los beneficios cosechados Y
sabéis qué fue lo que ocurrió Pues que a
partir de ese momento la producción se
disparó y con ella también las
exportaciones de repente el sector
petrolero colombiano cobró vida fijaos
de esta forma mientras la producción de
su vecino venezolano hacía aguas
Colombia cobraba cada vez más y más peso
en el sector petrolero de América Latina
los niveles de producción alcanzados
hubieran sido completamente
inimaginables apenas unos cuantos años
antes claro que también había algunos
problemas la caída de los precios del
petróleo en el año 2015 por ejemplo
redujo la inversión en este sector en
cerca de un 30% y la perforación de
nuevos pozos en más del 80 y sabéis cuál
fue el problema Pues el problema más
importante es que el gobierno de Juan
Manuel Santos tuvo que plantear una
reforma tributaria para contener la
caída de los ingresos Fiscales que
generaba El crudo digamos que el tesoro
colombiano pues había vuelto muy
dependiente de los nuevos ingresos
públicos que había traído consigo el oro
negro pero no nos desviemos sea como sea
pese a todo el sector se consolidó y las
exportaciones de hidrocarburos
continuaron ganando peso entre las
exportaciones colombianas hoy esta
industria es responsable de más de un
tercio de todas las exportaciones del
país en cierto modo amigos amigas
Hablamos de una especie de milagro
petrolero que contribuyó a cambiar el
país en apenas una década entre los años
2003 2013 el país pasó de tener casi que
importar crudo a convertirse por ejemplo
en un importante proveedor de Estados
Unidos y por supuesto detrás de toda
esta historia estuvo la llegada de miles
y miles de millones de dólares y sabéis
qué pues que justo ahora la falta de
inversión durante años en la industria
petrolera internacional y la invasión
rusa de Ucrania Podrían haber puesto
sobre la mesa una nueva era Dorada para
los hidrocarburos colombianos sin
embargo el nuevo presidente ha dicho que
nanay que la explotación del petróleo no
tiene cabida en Colombia de verdad lo ha
dicho atentos
[Música]
y Leo no
a finales del 2021 en plena campaña
electoral por la presidencia de Colombia
El futuro de la industria petrolera era
un tema relevante en la agenda económica
de los candidatos la oposición más
contundente era por supuesto la de
Gustavo Petro que prometía Ni más ni
menos que el cese de las concesiones
petroleras fijaos
cesa la contratación de exploración de
petróleo en Colombia mensaje vamos hacia
una economía productiva nuestra
activista habrá una transición tranquila
pero segura y seria que empieza el
primer día de gobierno Pues bien
finalmente este candidato se convirtió
el 19 de junio del 2022 en el presidente
electo de la república de Colombia y en
noviembre de ese mismo año tan solo un
año después de su promesa se lanzó un
discurso aún más arriesgado en la
conferencia de la ONU sobre cambio
climático presta mucha atención la
crisis climática sólo se supera si
dejamos de consumir hidrocarburos
es hora de desvalorizar la economía de
los hidrocarburos con fechas
definidas para su final la solución es
un mundo sin petróleo y sin carbón pero
esperad un momento porque el verdadero
bombazo llegó el de enero de 2023 cuando
Irene Vélez la ministra de minas y
energía confirmó que Bogotá ya no
firmará nuevos contratos de explotación
petrolera decidimos también que no vamos
a conceder nuevos contratos de
exploración de gas y de petróleo eso ha
sido por supuesto muy polémico a nivel
nacional por supuesto esto ha generado
mucho temor no solo entre el sector
petrolero sino en toda la industria y
prácticamente en toda la economía
colombiana perderá este país una de sus
fuentes de dólares e ingresos públicos
más importantes está acaso en riesgo la
seguridad del abastecimiento energético
[Música]
Y es que veréis actualmente Colombia
mantiene 330 contratos de exploración y
explotación los cuales seguirán
produciendo hidrocarburos tanto para el
mercado interno como para la exportación
durante aproximadamente 10 años La
pregunta es y después de eso qué pues
esto es exactamente lo que dice el
presidente Petro fijaos según las
proyecciones de la agencia internacional
de energía nos quedan cinco años de
exportación de Carbón y 10 de petróleo
la transición tiene que ver con dos
aspectos uno lograr que las Divisas que
dejamos de obtener por exportar carbón y
petróleo se han reemplazadas en la misma
magnitud por exportaciones de energías
limpias y turismo principalmente dos
conseguir que nuestro propio consumo
interno de Carbón y petróleo se
reemplace electrificando el transporte
cambiando nuestra matriz energética y
descarbonizando la producción Gustavo
Petro 21 de enero de 2023 habrá
transición estrictamente energética pero
manteniendo la exportación de petróleo
en niveles que nos permitan disponer de
las Divisas que el país necesita Yo
diría que la petrolera durará unos 15
años José Antonio Ocampo ministro de
hacienda de Colombia es decir que parece
que más o menos Tiene un plan forzar la
transición energética La pregunta es si
logrará en 10 años merece la pena perder
miles y miles de millones de dólares de
ingresos potenciales en un país que
sigue siendo muy pobre y que tiene
tantas carencias Como por ejemplo en
infraestructuras
[Música]
Al fin y al cabo qué queréis que os diga
los datos son contundentes la industria
de hidrocarburos es fundamental para la
estabilidad económica del país la
financiación nacional y la de los
departamentos y municipios cerca del 40%
de las exportaciones dependen de este
sector El 20% de los ingresos Fiscales
de la nación y el 76% de las regalías
diversificar la canasta exportadora debe
ser un objetivo pero no a Costa de
marchitar la industria comunicado de la
asociación colombiana de petróleo y gas
20 de enero de 2023 amigos amigas la
polémica y el miedo a perder miles de
millones de dólares en inversión
extranjera ingresos públicos fue tal que
el propio Petro parece haber dado marcha
atrás al menos ligeramente Sí sigue
teniendo la Diana la industria de los
hidrocarburos y posiblemente pues la
concesión de nuevas licencias de
exploración y producción se desplome
Pero al menos en el plan de transición
energética presentado se contemplan
nuevas concesiones pero sea como sea el
futuro de esta industria en Colombia no
parece particularmente a la dueña y la
pregunta es es suficiente el paso atrás
dado por el presidente Petro Qué impacto
Podría tener para Colombia que este
presidente cumpliera sus planes pues
atentos
del Milagro a la debacle petrolera
queridos amigos las palabras siempre
siempre cuentan pero las declaraciones
de un presidente lo suelen hacer mucho
más con su discurso Petro a calcinado la
confianza de un sector que iba viento en
popay a toda vela de hecho en 2022 la
inversión en exploración por ejemplo
alcanzó su mejor registro desde el año
2014 Pues bien Ahora se espera que en
2023 la tendencia se dé la vuelta y la
inversión vuelva a caer y eso que
hablamos de concesiones ya formalizadas
y ojo Porque si los planes de Petro se
consolidan Entonces los problemas Irán
mucho más allá de las petroleras la
entrada de Divisas en el país o incluso
los propios ingresos del gobierno
hablamos por ejemplo de miles y miles de
empleos o de que el precio de los
combustibles en el país podría
encarecerse lo que perjudicaría el
ingreso de millones de familias pero es
que ni siquiera eso es todo
Y es que veréis el cese de la producción
petrolera en 10 o 15 años podría traer
consigo otro gran problema la seguridad
del suministro energético Por qué Pues
porque el sistema eléctrico colombiano
es muy pero que muy dependiente de la
generación hidroeléctrica para que os
hagáis una idea Durante los periodos de
normalidad hidrológica la generación
hidroeléctrica puede llegar a abastecer
más de tres cuartas partes de toda la
demanda sin embargo cuando se producen
fenómenos como el niño y los
consiguientes periodos de sequía
Entonces el país tiene un problema y
tiene un problema muy serio hasta ahora
los hidrocarburos han solventado la
papeleta pero si esto se termina todo
podría complicarse y mucho Sea como sea
ya lo veis Colombia parece dispuesta a
sacrificar decenas de miles de millones
de dólares y miles de empleos para
luchar contra el calentamiento global y
sabéis que ahora la pregunta es para
todos vosotros qué os parece el plan de
Colombia estáis de acuerdo con el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro dejadnos
nuestras impresiones por aquí abajo los
comentarios y hablamos debate Y como
siempre si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros avise al politic si es que
aún no lo habéis hecho una vez más
muchas Gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]